[Música]
bueno no sean malpensados hoy vengo sin
pelos lo que pasa que esto ya como
algunos de mis alumnos incluso los
compañeros de facultad saben es un tic y
lo llevas y lo llevo si se me ha
olvidado
mira década de los 70 esos años en los
que los niños podíamos ir a la playa y
no hacía falta crema de protección solar
los veranos para pasar la tórrida tarde
de mi tierra de cádiz los vigilantes de
la playa super hero americano el estreno
de verano azul llegaba la tarde
bocadillo de chorizo manillar
al bosque prohibido era un bosque muy
simple para nosotros muy grande
eucaliptos enormes pero era prohibido
según mi madre
te podrías perder y era verdad porque
oponía marcas o igual no salías porque
para nosotros era enorme que pudiera
morder una culebra bueno con mordernos
devorar o picar un ala picarte un
alacrán o escorpión o peor cortarte con
una lata oxidada y eso significaba el
terror de los niños de entonces la
inyección del tétano porque para los
queridos amigos millennials si no lo
sabéis en aquellos tiempos todo mal se
solucionaba de dos maneras o con un
pinchazo o con un supositorio las dos
cosas se ponen en el mismo sitio y no me
gusta
no voy a explicar a los 1000 én es lo
que es un supositorio ahora
bueno la cosa era entrar y era él era
indefectible y vamos a encontrar seguro
una camada de gatitos o perritos que
para un niño lo mismo le da la cosa era
ser el primero despistar al grupo porque
en una pandilla siempre en toda pandilla
hay un cruel yo entonces ya veía que con
esa gente no tiene nada que ver los
despistaba volvíamos a casa luego
volvíamos a por los gatitos y a un lugar
seguro mi casa teníamos unos padres como
dios manda que nos permitían todo y nos
inculcaron esos valores
bueno con esos antecedentes y de
aquellos polvos estos lodos hoy por hoy
y desde que me independicé de casa de
mis padres bastante mayorcito pero me
independicé o he vivido con gatos o con
perros o como ahora con los dos
actualmente
convivo con once gatos equipo de fútbol
me faltan los suplentes y mi perra que
luego la presentaré a mi casa además es
una residencia canina particular y claro
pues es fácil que los fines de semana
allí se encuentren pues los 11 gatos más
los de los vecinos más 56 perros
se puede se puede pero claro
lo que gastas en esto te permitiría ir
al cine una vez por semana
es como una espada láser y luego vais a
ver que tiene ciertos poderes yo soy un
poco friki de marvel y eso estaba claro
que iba a salir mi hija me dijo papá no
irás a hablar de marvel y de superhéroes
sí
como en febrero me cae como un piano de
esos en la película de buster keaton que
te cae un piano encima pero con un
número que pone 50 me caen cincuenta
años en febrero pues mis amigos
últimamente están muy gracioso y simple
me dicen gregorio tío vas a morir vamos
que lo escribiendo sale en la prensa
murió un chaval un señor de cádiz
devorado por sus animales ya olía y los
vecinos dirán los de siempre decías
buenos días por la mañana
no tengo la base en el mercadona pero se
veía venir
bueno últimamente ya me está dando esos
comentarios sobre todo porque estoy en
plena crisis de los 50
con esos antecedentes de que os voy a
hablar cuando yo le dije a mi hija pues
voy a hacer una charla sobre el amor me
dice
pero su uso sobre los animales avales
entonces nada perfecto y aunque vaya a
hablar aquí del poder tremendo que tiene
el amor hacia los animales como medio
para educar en valores que luego regulan
las relaciones interpersonales cuando
son adultos me voy a centrar en gatos y
perros pero lo hago extensible a todos
los animales porque es inadmisible que
venga un alumno y te diga yo tengo un
perrito lo cuido lo quiero mucho y luego
en el jardín del colegio lo ves
aplastando caracoles no es congruente
algo falla
en españa hay 4 de cada 10 hogares
tienen mascotas 20 millones se estima y
no la mayoría no son perros y gatos son
aves pequeños reptiles roedores algunos
mamíferos que están ahora de moda pero
los perros superan con creces el número
de los números de gatos en las casas en
los gatos tienen unas sidras
connotaciones y yo
quiero que se me nota en la cara
soy that 1 pero además sé por qué
me vais a ayudar a hacer una prueba
os pido por favor que levantes la mano a
aquellos y aquellas que os sintáis más
afines tengáis o no tengáis penséis
tener o no más afines a los gatos
levantar la mano y mirar alrededor
bien ahora levantar a los que os sintáis
más afines a los perros
y ahora los que os dé igual pero porque
os gustan los dos
bueno los que no levantan la mano no
sabíais siquiera esto a qué no
vale
yo he tenido la gran suerte de ser
maestro me gusta más maestro que
profesor maestro y ver en los ojos de
los niños ese brillo que tiene los niños
en el día de reyes o el día de la
cabalgata ese brillo que es especial y
que eso da gasolina al maestro para
seguir en una profesión tan dura pero lo
he conseguido no enseñando la diferencia
entre los artrópodos
y el número de patas que tiene una araña
no no no lo he conseguido en tutorías en
ratos libres y contando anécdotas sobre
lo que pasaba en mi casa incluso era de
mayor muchas veces encuentra por lo que
hay y me dice que gregorio cuantos
animales tienes
y me da hasta vergüenza decírselo
entonces ese es el brillo que yo vengo
aquí a reclamar tenemos que utilizar el
amor hacia los animales y como lo que
tenemos más cerca son las mascotas para
consolidar la educación en valores
mirad como he dicho antes soy gatuno y
además por una razón hace poco
investigando para esta charla me di
cuenta de algo que no era de lo que yo
era consciente sabéis que el gato es el
es la única especie animal que decidió
ser domesticada directa y el perro no el
perro no lo decidió lo hizo el hombre
para protegerse de los lobos y de otras
alimañas y el perro dijo ah pues
encantado de la muerte sea perfecto el
gato dijo entre 8.000 y 5.000 antes de
cristo en además en egipto tuvo que ser
en egipto que hoy yo quiero hacer una
especie de pacto yo te quito las ratas
de los de los de los campos y tú me das
de comer bueno y de ahí nació la
domesticación del gato pero qué pasa que
el gato no se sabe independiente y nunca
se ve subordinado claro
investigando investigando veo que hay
estudios que dicen
y es que hay ciertas características en
las personas que le inclinan más hacia
hacia escoger un gato escoger un perro
la mía la verdad es que ya después de
mucho hablar con gente preparada la
tengo clara y hoy voy a hacer una
confesión aquí
hola me llamo goyo
y soy procrastinador
qué quiere decir eso
que por eso me molan los gatos yo voy a
poner un ejemplo
yo estoy la cocina recostado sobre la
encimera tomando un café y mirando al
gato que está comiendo veo que el gato
se mete debajo del mueble coge una
pelota de papel albal se pone a jugar
como mes y se la lleva al jardín en el
jardín me asomo y veo que está jugando
con una fila de hormigas que se están
llevando semillitas se le empiezan a
subir por las patas se sacude aprovecha
que pasa por allí mi perra lola le pega
un gancho de derecha y sigue corriendo
mariposa mosca saltamontes le da igual
se cuelga de la ropa escucha el ruido
del frigorífico cerrar y viene a la
cocina de repente viene a la cocina
busca la pelota ve que no está mira la
comida y se pone a comer
así somos los procrastinadores
yo creo que por eso me gustan tanto los
gatos
bueno
vayámonos entonces a la parte histórica
muy brevemente mira como he dicho el
gato deliciosas domesticado y fue el
antiguo egipto fue un animal que estaba
totalmente aferrado a la familia incluso
tenían deidades con atribuciones gato
una seta es la diosa base que se
representa con un cuerpo de mujer y
cabeza de gato
pero luego llegó la edad media y en la
edad media fueron perseguidos y
masacrados
y se asociaron a la brujería al frikismo
en fin y fueron masacrados por
centenares de millones lo pagó el hombre
muy caro con un montón de plagas y de
pestes y con la muerte de millones
decenas de millones de europeos
por qué digo esto bueno digo esto porque
quería hacer una defensa de los gatos lo
siento porque avis
había sido un sincero realmente pero
erais mayoría los que les prefería y los
perros yo me realmente esto es como
decir con qué hijo te quedas a cuál me
das
pero si es que me llama la atención
porque los programas en los pocos
programas que hay en cárceles son
centros de terapia con personas con
alzheimer incluso aquí en cádiz hay un
programa en el hospital puerta del mar
donde hay perros y conejos enanos que
van al área de pediatría y hacen la vida
de los niños allí un poco más amena
porque nunca hay datos bueno pues quería
aprovechar para hacer esa reivindicación
solamente se necesitan personas expertas
que los quieran y los conozcan y son
perfectamente posibles
no hay más preguntas señoría aquí
termina mi alegato a favor de los datos
y ahora nos vamos a volver al brillo de
los niños a ese brillo especial mirad
como profesor tengo muy buenos recuerdos
pero tengo algunos que son amargos y los
más amargo eran cuando por ejemplo
por imperativo de la dirección de los
planes de estudio de la programación
anual tenía que ir al foco los niños
el filósofo para mí en verdad son los
sitios en los que los animales estudian
el comportamiento de las personas se
aparece que el chimpancé está siendo
observado y el chip nunca viven no cabe
para denunciar decir qué estará pensando
ese de nosotros pues yo lo siento pero
como lo hacía de niño pues ellas ya
sabéis y es igual de mayor reconozco que
me encargaba y sé que hay aquí algún
alumno o alumna mía
me encargaba de aleccionarles y decirle
mira mira lo triste que está ese animal
pero luego llegaban a casa diciendo mamá
vengo del zoo
por favor que lo saquen de allí
bueno quizá no debería hacerlo pero
actúe en conciencia
esa vena animalista que llevaba montado
en bicicleta algo que prohibido a veces
eso es ya una medida importante pero yo
echo de menos programas en serios
programas consolidados no día de la
mascota bueno y para poner el ejemplo
que no es muy políticamente correcto del
día del abuelo y traemos al abuelo y el
abuelo cuenta sus cosas día de la
mascota perdón por el ejemplo traemos a
la mascota con él
la cesta eso no es el día de nada el día
a día es decir o ya no vamos al fondo
vamos a una protectora y les enseñamos
la miseria la ruindad de la gente que
abandona
no te enciendas goyo ya lo sé
horrible bueno yo conozco verdaderas
transformaciones en personas mayores que
han ido a una protectora y han visto la
realidad
bueno a lo mejor no hay que llevar a los
niños pero sí hay que empezar a hablar
desde una realidad que es el del
abandono
bueno pues esos brillos en los niños los
he visto sobre todo cuando les contaba
tres cosas sobre mis animales uno
yo no tengo gatos ni perros como que no
tienes gato ni perro gregorio no yo
convivo con una
los animales si yo les doy ellos me dan
ellos me dan cariño y yo pago la factura
no lo entendían pero luego llegaban a
casa y decían mamá
tú no tienes garra tú no tienes perro tú
convives con un perro al día siguiente
tenía la madre en tutoría del don
gregorio entonces no le pica esas cosas
a mi hijo bueno de acuerdo a igual no
tenía que haberlo hecho pero me salía y
ese brillo en los niños cuando veían que
el año pues igual es verdad igual no
poseemos igual no estamos en la cúspide
de los de los seres vivos
ese brillo no se me olvida
en no poseer el amor no entendido como
una posesión anda que no hay problemas
hoy en día por entender que el otro nos
pertenece
otra cosa que hacía que se encendiese
los ojos solo que esta vez un poco menos
jolgorios o era cuando le decía se me ha
muerto un gato
he tenido que dormir a un perro bueno la
verdad es que había gente que ni se
inmutaba pero otros lo normal era que se
le ponían los ojitos hace cuéntanos y
tal y le contaba fácilmente le contaba
porque los niños que no son tontos
simplemente son niños y lo pueden
entender además os digo una cosa no
temáis está demostrado que un niño a las
dos semanas se le ha ido el duelo y
queda para nosotros
bueno educar a los niños en la pérdida
en que no nada es para siempre y por
supuesto el amor tampoco lo he visto no
solo en mis hijos no sólo en los niños
también en mi hija tengo una maravillosa
hija
y
ella ha visto perder mascotas de niña de
adolescente y ahora de adulta y sigue
cuando se le muere alguna mascota no
pierde el tiempo de un refugio volver a
sacar sus gatos era tina dos gatos
adorables o no y fit y le prometí que se
lo diría
es que nos pasamos en los whatsapp oye
cómo está fit y como está o no pues mira
yo tengo aquí y tú cómo está por ciento
que es que no te preguntado desde el mes
pasado papá por cierto que me caso
avales se me ha pasado entre los
mensajes y fotos de vídeos y de gatos
bueno no hay que sobre proteger en mi
opinión a los niños frente a la pérdida
porque educa en la empatía yo no digo
que los niños haya que venga acá va
ayúdame
y por último el maltrato de ese brillo
en los niños cuando le hablas sobre el
maltrato es fatal pensar que la
violencia violencia se haga contra quien
se haga cuando se haga y cómo se haga de
acuerdo ahora bien
llegado a este punto me vais a permitir
la licencia d
nombrar mis animales los que me han
convertido en la persona que soy mejor o
peor os dije que eso tenía poder es
verdad
pues
se transforma en una magnífica chuleta
sí porque esto es hacer tres cosas a la
vez mirar la pantalla
pero ojito señor gris meñique noche
vaquita neko el cielito la familia
picapiedra al completo con pedro pablo
vilma y betty
los tres últimos los más pequeños rayito
para ti
los hermanos de la caja porque vinieron
en una cajita todos de golpe
tom salem
sabrina y los tres patitos capitán
garcía
mis cuatro perros danko como cuchi y
milán
lola y freud
ese gordo rubito
ese gordo rubito se encarga de bajarle
los humos a los perros que vienen a casa
para alojarse y decirles aquí hay 10
mandamientos de la convivencia gatuna
y persona de acuerdo
y lola es quien se encarga de
entrenarlos un equipazo en la
entrenadora la psicóloga el psicólogo y
el que paga las facturas que soy yo
bien para terminar
por favor esto es un cañón es un arma
poderosísima para educar en valores el
cariño y el respeto hacia los animales
que podéis hacer no tenéis que tener un
equipo de fútbol gatuno ni tenéis que
tener pedagogía ni ser para del maestro
nada simplemente basta con que hagáis lo
que hay que hacer cuando uno cree que no
puede hacer nada dar ejemplo decía que
el que dar ejemplo no es la mejor manera
de enseñar es la única
marvel os acordáis que iba a decirlo
stanley murió esta semana en 1962 puso
en boca de spiderman tener un gran poder
implica una gran responsabilidad nuestra
responsabilidad es dejar un mundo mejor
del que nos dejaron nuestros padres
[Aplausos]
[Música]